Narrator:
MAKING THIS MID-SIZE YACHT
STARTS WITH THE MOLD
FOR THE HULL.
THE TEAM SPRAYS A GEL COAT PAINT
ON TO THE ENTIRE INNER SURFACE
OF THE MOLD.
THIS PAINT WILL TRANSFER
TO THE HULL DURING MOLDING.
THEY LAYER FIBERGLASS STRIPS
AROUND A PVC FOAM CORE
AND CREATE A SERIES OF
DISTRIBUTION CHANNELS FOR RESIN.
THE CREW NOW DRAPES AN ENORMOUS
SHEET OF CLEAR PLASTIC
OVER THE MATERIALS AND THE MOLD
AND SEALS THE EDGES WITH TAPE.
THE CREW LEAVES A LOT OF SLACK
IN THE PLASTIC
TO CONFORM TO THE MOLD'S
DEEP RECESSES.
A VACUUM HOSE SUCTIONS OUT
THE AIR BENEATH THE PLASTIC.
THE CREW THEN CONNECTS PLASTIC
TUBING TO THE PORTS
IN THE DISTRIBUTION CHANNELS.
THE RESIN SATURATES
THE FIBERGLASS STRIPS
THAT SURROUND THE PVC FOAM CORE.
THE VACUUM SUCKS THE LAYERS
INTO A TIGHT SANDWICH
AND PULLS OUT MORE AIR
AND EXCESS RESIN.
THE RESIN CURES AND
THE FIBERGLASS LAYERS HARDEN.
THE NEXT DAY, THE TEAM REMOVES
THE PLASTIC SHEET
FROM THE MOLDED PART.
A CRANE LIFTS THE NEWLY MOLDED
HULL OUT OF THE MOLD.
THE GEL COAT HAS ADHERED TO IT,
GIVING IT A GLOSSY FINISH.
NEXT THEY CREATE THE DECK.
LIKE THE HULL, THE CREW MAKES
THE DECK MAINLY FROM FIBERGLASS.
A WORKER CUTS OUT THE STRIPS
IN DIFFERENT SIZES.
AFTER ARRANGING SOME OF THE
FIBERGLASS STRIPS IN THE MOLD,
THE CREW BUILDS UP THE DECK
IN CERTAIN AREAS,
USING PIECES OF BALSA WOOD.
A WORKER LAYS
MORE FIBERGLASS STRIPS
ENCAPSULATING THE BALSA WOOD.
THEY'LL LAMINATE THE LAYERS
WITH RESIN
THE WAY THEY DID WITH THE HULL.
THE CREW ALSO MAKES THE ROOF
STRUCTURE THE SAME WAY.
A BOAT BUILDER APPLIES PUTTY
TO THE FIBERGLASS
TO EVEN OUT ANY IRREGULARITIES.
AND AFTER GRINDING THE HARDENED
PUTTY SMOOTH,
THEY SPREAD POLISHING COMPOUND
ON ALL THE YACHT'S BODY PARTS.
USING A ROUTER, THE CREW CUTS
OUT HOLES FOR LIGHTS, PORTHOLES,
AND OTHER FEATURES.
AND NOW THE BIG MOMENT.
AFTER SIX MONTHS OF WORK,
LET THE GOOD TIMES BEGIN.